- Um...
(laughing)
(upbeat jazz music
- I love dark chocolate.
Chocolate makes me happy, man.
It gets me through some stressful days.
It's sweet. It just brings joy to my life.
What's there not to like about chocolate?
- Just thinking about chocolate
is making my mouth water
and it's making my heart happy
because chocolate has
always been a reward.
It's always been an indulgence.
Chocolate is the purest joy in the world
next to dogs and cats.
- I think 100% dark chocolate is gonna be
mind-blowingly amazing, super sweet.
Pure dark chocolate,
it's gonna be the best.
- Yeah.
So we are here at Tache
in the Lower East Side of New York City,
and we are going to
learn all about chocolate
and eventually try 100% pure chocolate.
So, Aditi, tell us a
little bit about Tache.
- Sure, so tache means
spot or smudge in French
because every time I'm wearing
my chef coat or my apron,
I usually have a smudge of
chocolate on it somewhere.
So hopefully you will leave
with a smudge of chocolate on you.
Actually, you don't have aprons, so...
(laughing)
Hopefully it'll be in your mouth.
So, I do have a variety of chocolate.
So, white chocolate, not
real chocolate, guys.
- What?
- Yeah, white chocolate is made up of
cocoa butter, milk solids, and sugar.
So, it contains absolutely no cacao.
- My mind is blown right now.
So this isn't real chocolate?
- Let's go up the scale.
So, let's try some milk chocolate.
- Loving it.
- This is what heaven is like.
- The main differences
between milk and dark,
milk chocolate contains
a ton more milk in it
and it also contains some cocoa mass,
some vanilla to give it
a little bit of flavor,
and some cocoa butter.
- It says it's only 35% chocolate,
so it can only get
better from here, right?
- Yeah, exactly. It has to.
- So, the next one that
you guys are trying
is an 81% dark chocolate.
I think you'll be able to taste
more of the nuances in it.
- This is a different level.
This is sort of like,
there's a bitterness to this.
- It's just like blowing my
mind to taste pure chocolate.
- It's like, and we haven't
even reached pure chocolate yet.
We're at like, 81%.
- We haven't reached nirvana?
- No. (laughing)
- Obviously, 100% chocolate
is 100% chocolate,
but what does that mean?
- So, 100% chocolate comes
with no frills attached,
so it is just an organic chocolate mass.
Basically, they take cacao beans
and they ground them up nice and fine,
and then they form it
into a nice little brick
that looks like that.
When we get it, we just chip away at it
and put it into our
double boiler over there
and melt it and make it
into wonderful concoctions.
I like that.
- All right, all right.
- [Aditi] I think that looks great.
- Let's get ready for
these silky mouth feels.
- All right.
(laughing)
- Heaven tastes a little
different than I thought.
Your chocolate is definitely bold.
- Whoa, man. Bitter is just it.
That is like the best
way to describe this.
- I don't know, kind of
like the taste of tobacco
or like, a cigar.
- So this is like literally day and night.
I mean, not just based off how it looks,
but definitely by the way it tastes.
- This is like a little kid
when their parents give
them wine and they're like,
"Oh, I know this is supposed
to taste good, but it doesn't."
- It's an acquired taste.
- I guess I was naive in not knowing
what the taste of chocolate was,
because the chocolate
we know is mixed with
vanilla, and cocoa butter, and sugar,
and all these great things.
It just shows just how brilliant
the chocolatiers of the world are.
Having the more pure
chocolate made me realize
I'm a basic chocolate
lover, and that's okay.
- I'm gonna ask you to rest
a little piece of chocolate
in between your tongue
and the roof of your mouth
and kind of swish it around your pallette
like you would do with fine wine.
- [Man] What? We're getting fancy as hell
in this chocolate factory.